hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today's lesson and on the one
gene one enzyme hypothesis this is a
hypothesis that was first proposed in
1941 by two scientists whose names were
Beetle and Tatum and they had this idea
that each gene in the genome coded for
an individual enzyme and specifically
that each one of these genes that coded
for each individual enzyme and each
individual enzymes us impacted a
specific step in a metabolic pathway
what do we mean by a metabolic pathway
well for example the synthesis of the
amino acid arginine in south is a
stepwise process in so the precursor and
then this precursors is transformed into
other things one after the other until
arguing is eventually synthesized by the
cell and so we went and had this idea
that there were these gene decoded for
an enzyme and that enzyme would catalyze
one step in this process and that
another gene would code for another
enzyme that catalyzes another staff and
another gene was code for another
environment catalyzed another step and
so on and so forth and they were correct
in that these kinds of gene and
metabolic pathways certainly to exist
and are very important to cellular
function and their idea that one can
contribute to metabolic pathways in this
manner through this one gene one enzyme
interface with a major contribution to
the field of early molecular genetics
however we now understand it to be kind
of an oversimplification and we know the
real processes in a Cell are much more
complicated so for example we now know
that many genes encode nan and dine
proteins so for example proteins like
insulin which is a signaling hormone it
helps to regulate blood sugar or protein
like keratin which is a structural
protein it gives strength to hair and
skin and nails or transport proteins
like for example hemoglobin which is a
protein in red blood cells that helps to
transport oxygen and carbon dioxide
between the lungs and the tissues and
also proteins and antibodies which are
important in immunity and helping us to
fight off pathogens so these are all
examples of proteins which are coded for
by genes but which are not actually
enzyme which is which is a certain major
exceptions this one gene one enzyme
hypothesis another major exception is
that many proteins are actually composed
of more than one polypeptide and the
Echenique polypeptides is coded by a
separate gene so actually all of the
proteins that I mentioned up here from
insulin to keratin to hemoglobin to
antibodies these are all composed with
at least two polypeptides if not three
or four and each of these is coded by a
separate hmm and so this gives us a
different way of looking at this
original hypothesis knowing that each
gene can code for different polypeptides
so that the final proteins will contain
components coded for by many genes it's
also true there are many genes that code
for various types of non-coding RNAs
what do I mean when I say non-coding
well we typically think that a gene
codes for protein in that the gene is
transcribed in the process of
transcription to make an mRNA transcript
and that mRNA transcript is then
translated protein it may not apply to
them during the process of translation
so that is that pathway for gene
expression in the stuff but there are
certainly many genes that code for
various types of non-coding RNA so for
example genes that code for our RNA
the catalytic portion of the ribosome
genes that code for tRNAs which are the
transfer RNAs is bringing amino acids to
the ribosome during that process of
translation that I just mentioned
there's also a whole host of regulatory
RNA many many different kinds micro RNA
small interfering RNAs long non-coding
RNAs and more than I can possibly
mention here and they have a wide
variety of regulatory functions in the
cell they're very very critical to
cellular function if you're interested
in learning more about these different
types of regulatory RNA please see my
video on that topic
another exception to the original one
gene one enzyme hypothesis by Beadle and
Tatum is that many multi exonic genes
produce transcripts that are
alternatively spliced what does this
mean well multi exonic means a gene that
would transcribe into an mRNA there are
more than one exon there and these
different exponents can be joins
together or spliced out in differential
patterns or process of alternative
splicing which means that from one gene
that creates one mRNA transcript many
different proteins can result if you're
interested in learning more about
alternative splicing and how that
increases protein diversity in a cell
then please see my video on alternative
splicing that is it for today and our
discussion of the one gene one enzyme
hypothesis thanks for watching biology
professors